hello everyone and welcome I'm live on
Twitch right now if you're watching the
twitch chat I'm saying this because I'm
going to post out this on YouTube as
soon as the stream is done
um as always Nintendo Direct was during
my work hours which meant that I
couldn't catch up on it so we are
catching up on it right now because I
spend virtually no time on Twitter
anymore maybe a minute a day it's so
little I have avoided absolutely all
spoilers except for one friend texting
me saying that he really liked this
direct so I have no idea what's in it
I am hoping for Zelda because the
release date is soon and I know that
they said it would be the next six
months of games so that's what I'm
really excited about and I am very very
very excited but I actually have no idea
what's going to be in this so this is
going to be totally fresh for me please
don't spoil it chat 44 minutes is longer
than I was expecting but I'm down I'm
excited
let's do it tell me if I need to adjust
the audio
please note due to covid-19 release
dates and other information presented in
this video subject to change potential
updates please check the official
Nintendo website and social media
channels as well as those of something
else
oh Twitter was down during the direct I
didn't even know that that's wild
[Music]
maybe we'll get a little updated about
Pokemon as well
[Music]
Metroid
Pikmin
could have gone either way it was a
strange looking Metroid you know I never
played Pikmin actually I played a little
bit but not very much
you know people really love them
[Music]
it's very cute
dude really just got pooped out by a
spaceship well all right
[Music]
I I reckon uh a uh rounded Pikmin collab
would pop off
[Music]
I look like a giant ball sack
I should I should give these games a try
they look extremely unique
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God is it a dog
um game of the year
[Music]
excuse me
his name's Ochi
I would die for him
[Music]
no oh Chi what is that
you have Pikmin lokia survival horror
oh my God it's a survival horror with a
dog and Friends
[Music]
I have no idea what that game is
um I registered that it's Pikmin and I
know vaguely how the concept of Pikmin
Works mechanically
in terms of like
you get more of them
yo this scary as hell
is Pikmin scary
It's like Star Girls
hello everyone wow
and I'll be your guide for today's
Nintendo Direct
[Music]
that was the latest trailer for Pikmin
4. certainly was
a dog-like creature was spotted what
kinds of things will it show us
please look forward to more information
in the future
let's see our first batch of Nintendo
switch headlines I love him
I'm scaring the Kelly Star protocol
introducing volume 3 of the Xenoblade
Chronicles 3 expansion that is a very
good game if you haven't played
Xenoblade Chronicles 3 it is very very
good
though I have not played hello it's a
Masha the newest hero and a refined
lapidarist I will say hello to her hello
you can use special or to craft
accessories that can bestow various
effects
challenge battles with roguelike
elements are also being added select
only one character and battle wave after
wave of enemies
for every win you'll earn more Heroes
and special abilities
rack up victories With Your Heroes and
set your sights on the final stage
you might also get special in-game
outfits as a reward
and coming in volume 4 later this year
tell me that's a good heads up I like
this story spoilers
nothing's gonna get through to him
it's also a very pretty game
the Xenoblade you're right that is a
spoiler that's unfortunate that's a
choice oh well February 15th
[Music]
shake it amigo
I feel like every direct has to have a
really quirky music game I still haven't
played the trombone what was it called I
don't remember
during his songs
[Music]
follow the instructions on screen to
pose and dance trombone champ that's it
there you go
an unexpected high five is just a slap
let's be honest
an unexpected something unexpected might
happen and it's a high five again that
is just somebody being hit
doesn't work that way compete online in
world party those with the lowest scores
in each round will be eliminated keep
the beat and aim for first place
[Music]
40 songs are included spanning a
multitude of genres from around I'm sure
this would be fun and when I went to
Japan I spent a lot of time in arcades
playing games that look like this when
Samba de Amigo party central doesn't
really appeal to me because I
I tend to like if I'm gonna play a
rhythm game where I'm moving I'm gonna
do it in um via at this point got a
passion for fashion not particularly as
somebody who's wearing fashion
sweatpants
and express yourself here you'll aim to
become a stylish influencer and you're
in luck maybe it'll make me better maybe
I'll get stylish
give them a like if you dig their Style
or suggest new outfits for them to grow
as an influencer
[Music]
now it's time for fashion design
options
Personal Touch to give your item a final
flourish
you can get the items you just walk
around talking to by liking people about
that clothes
mix and match your favorites to create
new looks
connecting online you can expand your
friend Circle and grow your brand
got an eye for fashion it is very
strange to go from instead of Life
Chronicles exclusively on I guess Pikmin
Center blade
to a dance game to a fashion game it's
an odd Cadence but
I respect that they have a lot of
variety into these Dark Worlds I just
wonder if the people who are going to
play that fashion game are the kind of
people who tune into a Nintendo director
DLC for the roguelite action platformer
dead cells
Venture through the Castle's hellish
halls and outskirts is a Victor Belmont
and Alex very good game
did not know that they had a Castlevania
combat 12 original this is incredible
from the Castlevania series accompany
you during your quest in dead cells
return oh my God sinking its teeth into
Nintendo switch March 6th pre-orders
begin today that's very cool
and extremely unexpected I never would
have seen that coming narrative puzzle
Adventures
as you navigate through a perilous world
your decisions and the alliances impact
your journey and the entire server
Tron identity launches first for
consoles on Nintendo switch this April
who's all right it's like Bethel writing
up a storm there excited about it
well that can't be good the time-bending
murder mystery Ghost Trick returns in HD
very excited to play find out more about
it being a ghost talk about uh talk to
the mic about it next week I imagine we
can talk about it
was it it might have been oh someone
else said it was the pre-show yeah I
didn't watch
thanks I did not watch the pre-show
Ghost Trick Phantom that's why did they
announce that during the game awards
that's so cool
I completely missed that one sorry
everybody I was talking my bad two
connected worlds one suspenseful
Thriller
top five
so uh yeah never know
[Music]
I'm gonna move myself a little bit
higher the sake of the subtitles
foreign
[Music]
I said that just as somebody turned into
a cat
foreign
taking the power to rescue her
imprisoned mother she Ventures very
curious about what this is super
unexpected I'm going to that Forest
I'm going to become a witch and save
money
there she was a little bit weird about
their worldly bayonettes speaking that
way to be honest
you'll control both witch and Demon at
the same time harness erases magic oh
sorry audacity to travel through this
mysterious and dangerous Forest
they'll need to work together in battle
as well
[Music]
ceresa cannot attack and can only
support Cheshire by magically binding
enemies
I think this this is probably going to
be really good
or stop an aggressive one to focus on
another
strategically use each character's
abilities to win battles
honestly I think this looks really cool
like the the the duo uh gain strength as
they continue their Disney very pretty
the combat looks rad New Paths can be
opened and battles can be more easily
swayed in your favor
Ken cereza and Cheshire find their
happily ever after
Bayonetta Origins cereza and the lost
demon proud I like it the Nintendo
switch system March 17th
pre-orders are available now yeah I
reckon that that is going to end up
being surprisingly very good
next put money on it take a look at this
oh I will thank you sir whatever this is
I will look at it I promise it's
Splatoon
foreign you can always guarantee
Splatoon will show up in a direct and
it's kind of sad not having smash
anymore
I miss the hype for every direct for
that to be a new Smash
character reveal
yeah I should also give the context that
I'm not a Splatoon person I did play
quite a bit of the first game
it just didn't hold me for as long as
I've been supporting it but I do think
that they've the support
that they have given Splatoon is
commendable
[Music]
how big the community still is I do know
a few people who still play it this paid
DLC includes two waves of content
the first wave is incopolis make this
splatastic place from the original
Splatoon game your stomping grounds
it's cool this is booyah base it's got
some pretty nifty weapons and gear you
might spot a few familiar faces
alongside directions
yeah looks like that the original Plaza
is like DLC here now which is cool Turf
battle
show
and amiibo functionality all work in the
same way here too
[Music]
so really well in Japan
noted
the squid sisters will also perform here
during Splat fests
eat a mix of old school and freshness
then head over to incopolis
[Music]
hey Philly if you showed somebody this
you're like this is video games and this
is all you showed them
it'll be very confusing
like Hatsune Miku but but Splatoon is
very weird I love it I'm down more weird
in video games I like it
oh what's this
I don't know what is it
you have my attention
this is still Splatoon 3
foreign
cool trailer
The Vibes are very near
[Music]
is it like
story content
whoa
that was cool
whatever it was wave one order launches
this spring
wave two side order will launch in the
future it is very yokotara yeah I mean I
guess we didn't say near the night looks
really cool I don't know what it is this
will be available later today on
Nintendo eShop
many people have played Splatoon 3 since
its launch
allegedly thank you all very much
we hope players will be able to enjoy
the game even more with the upcoming
paid expansion pass
please look forward to more information
about Splatoon 3 in the future
let's see some more Nintendo switch
headlines
Adventure awaits Mickey and friends on
illusion Island Disney pumping out games
man Mickey Mouse Minnie Mouse Donald
Duck and Goofy
embark on a new adventure to find three
magical books and save the mysterious
island of manoth
run
jump
and swing to explore every nook and
cranny of the eye animation is really
nice
[Music]
unlocking special abilities you can
reach new places and find secret areas
cross large chasms with Boost jump I
really like the animation found barriers
to open new spaces and glide through the
air to reach distance to sort of like
outlines cartoon style of the player
characters
Dola thicker environment is like a
really nice touch sure a hug for extra
health
play leapfrog for larger jumps or drop a
rope to lend a hand drop a rope to lend
a hand sounds like a human I don't know
why you might discover New Paths
sometimes you just gotta drop a route
man while exploring the island you'll
meet unusual allies and dangerously it
does look like Rayman
study their movements carefully to
figure out the secrets to Victory
join Nikki and friends on a high flying
Adventure in Disney illusion Island
swinging onto Nintendo switch July 28th
pre-orders begin today
is just the next six months I wonder how
far ahead it goes what if cuphead but
Mickey I would be very surprised if that
game is hard
coming to Future wins let's go
past DLC wave two includes Hector emblem
of strength all right okay Hector how
you doing unleash counter attacks
there is only one person
emblem of Acumen cast magic spells who
am I kidding everybody in fire emblems
Hot 100 of them all hot
Camilla emblem
to hinder enemies
wave three includes
krom and Robin emblem of bonds
overwhelmed foes with sword and Magic
attacks
Veronica emblem of Heroes
see some and additional allies to fight
for your cause there's actually quite a
few animals we like nice to recruit
these new emblems
and in wave four a new story called Bell
xenologue will be unlocked
thank you for answering our prayers who
is it that's putting your words engages
good as three houses I don't think so I
think um
some of the gameplay is improved
expansion pass for the Fire Emblem
engage game Launches on the Nintendo
switch but I don't think the story is
anywhere near as interesting
[Music]
take control of your destiny I recognize
these characters this is reverie a world
in which deities known as aspirations I
recognize them so well when a megacorp
endangers the harmony between reverie
and our world the future of humanity
hangs in the balance
this narrative Adventure harness
yourself
Clairvoyance to travel between worlds
okay I'm playing this game see the
future
and decide Humanity's fate many
branching story paths along with a
riveting soundtrack by Celeste composer
Lena Rayne set the stage for your
journey eventually you'll side with one
of the six aspirations like Bond
power or chaos to change the story's
outcome to which Destiny do you Aspire
Harmony the fall of reverie launches
first for consoles on Nintendo switch
this June
[Music]
these games will have you rolling
octopath traveler 2 is just around the
corner
after today's Nintendo Direct a demo
containing the game's opening hours will
be available on Nintendo eShop
eight new stories await which path will
you take first
who will your allies be and where will
your journey leave you I think this is
also maybe the second time
we've seen Big Shots February 24th I've
seen he talked about a few times
of objects in this remaster of we love
Katamari
[Music]
I really liked octopath a zoo it's one
of the first games I ever streamed if
not the first game I ever streamed
actually new features include playing as
the young king of all and I really liked
it five new challenges I just don't feel
need to play more
active Nintendo switch online members
can play a free gameplay
Katamari I will play that again
so satisfying in such a weird way in
this turn-based RPG
freely Traverse a breathtaking World
meet characters from all walks of life
and devastate foes with time I'm
fortunate how similar it looks to
octopus without being as pretty and
retro inspired Tunes from the renowned
yasunori mitsuda a guest composer for
the game
sea of stars sails onto Nintendo switch
August 29th
a free demo will launch later today on
Nintendo eShop cool
duke it out in this free to play online
multiplayer this is so fast-paced God
damn yeah
smashing through it oh my God I love it
Striker skills to dominate each match
course trajectory from a fall not many
games are in this like
so far it's so so quick
or knock opponents out of the arena with
explosive moves like Omega Striker so
Rec's really fun to watch because of
that the only problem as a free-to-play
game Nintendo fan is that sometimes
there are so many games that I forget
what they are
like there's too much too much
information calling Labyrinth a
collection of the first three etrian
Odyssey games is coming to Nintendo
switch remastered in HD many Treasures
lie deep within a massive laptop it's
paths are intertwined and vicious and
that is extremely sickening a blank map
is your only guide
by drawing the map as you explain oh you
can progress even further
no I can't even handle looking at that
Venture into the Labyrinth with five
adventurers
as the guild leader you'll assign them
roles like the allies
but be warned every Adventure is brought
with Danger
should you fall in battle you can change
your team and learn new skills to
strengthen your party before challenging
the Pokemons with humans
Pokemons with humans it's Pokemon 24
newly drawn character illustrations are
included
yeah I've not I've not heard of some
difficulty options and a new audience
smoother exploration
etrian Odyssey Origins yeah having this
on Nintendo switch I guess there's three
of them each game in the collection will
also be available separately on Nintendo
eShop
pre-orders begin today on Nintendo eShop
get your Tactical skills ready
calling all strategy fans the Advanced
Wars OnePlus 2 reboot Camp games only a
couple of months away join Andy Max
Sammy and More in two full-story
campaigns each one filled with colorful
terms I have a lot of friends who are
very excited about this flex your
strategically I guess I am too it's a
multitude of modes nice inside your own
maps and share them with friends plus go
head to head in local and online play
Advanced Wars OnePlus 2 reboot Camp
comes to Nintendo switch April 21st
pre-orders begin today on Nintendo eShop
yes
[Music]
a new story will unfold in the Kirby's
Return to Dreamland Deluxe game
magolor The interdimensional Traveler
from the main Adventure has lost his
power it must escape the realm between
dimensions
[Music]
I also just love Kobe I'm a big fan of
Kobe
[Music]
is a basic attack and jump
to regain magalore's Powers you'll need
to collect magic points by defeating
enemies
with magic points different abilities
can be restored and enhanced
improve magalore's levitation
or increase his attack range I just
think they're all just very cute
there are over 20 interdimensional
stages to explore
[Music]
up to four players on the same system on
the same system together that's awesome
Ken magalore restored his powers and
safely returned to his world that's
typical you can access this new
Macklemore clearing story mode yeah
cool
I was wondering if cubby would be in it
today's Nintendo Direct a demo will be
available on Nintendo eShop the Elder
ring box in the back do you know is
empty it's not again
[Music]
I think like very few people across
maybe on the deluxe launchers
February 24th pre-orders are available
now on Nintendo eShop
we hope you're looking forward to the
new story in Kirby's Return to Dreamland
Deluxe
next I love it here's some news about
Nintendo switch online it's just okay I
just really want Zelda man you know I
just really want Zelda
I really would appreciate it I think
it's gonna be here and if it's not then
I'm worried that it's delayed
[Music]
boy games are being added to Nintendo
hell yeah
on Nintendo switch you can play these
games anywhere just like you could back
in the day dude
Tetris
arrange the falling tetraminos and aim
for high school terrible at it
Super Mario Land 2 six golden coins
awesome
yeah this is like way overdue to the
extent that I had started to assume that
it wouldn't happen awaken the wind fish
to escape covalent Island such a [__]
good game dude
gargoyle's Quest never played a cool
realm Aspire brand from the ghosts and
Goblin series
this does make me really happy I am very
very very glad
they're doing this that said I'm not a
huge fan of the Nintendo online service
in general solve a murder mystery on the
supernatural Shadow I heard that that
game's terrible Metroid 2 return of
Samus destroy the metroids hiding on
planets very good
Wario Land three Traverse also very good
day and night based on your actions
laughs
Kirby's Dreamland absolute Banger God so
many of these games are so [__] good
this is awesome
I just feel like the online service is
kind of convoluted and very expensive
you can use the game in a lot of cases
Game Boy Pocket
or Game Boy Color screen whoa that's
really cool players can play compatible
games together locally or online
more games will be added in the future
love it very happy to hear it
love to see it across the board great
news
foreign
Boy advanced games are being added to
Nintendo switch online plus expansion
pack this would actually be enough for
me and I would have been like okay sick
and I wouldn't have needed any more from
this direct Super Mario which is so sad
like I'm so actively aware extra levels
that I will spend the rest of my life
buying the same Nintendo games for the
same price experience the origins at
full price micro games forever and it's
crazy that I'm happy about that isn't
that the spinning stick to the goal
they've got me I don't know this is part
of who I am now
Mario Kart
game created for a portable system
Mario and Luigi Superstar Saga Venture
through a zany world and fight with
equally zany attacks
so cute though the Legend of Zelda the
Minish Cap shrink to miniature size and
dive into a big adventure
[Music]
Circle and online play is supported for
compatible games and up to four players
can play together
yeah dude oh that's it man more games
will be added to this Library
[Music]
these Game Boy titles with the Nintendo
switch online membership I already have
one or play both Game Boy and Game Boy
advanced titles with the Nintendo switch
online
expansion pack oh no no that's just the
membership so it's like is that with
those features but I guess it would
anyway
select Game Boy titles
will be playable on Nintendo switch I
love it I love it I love it I love it
today's Nintendo Direct you'll be able
to play the game boy and Game Boy
Advance titles we introduced
please look forward to more information
about Nintendo switch online and
Nintendo switch online plus expansion
pack in the future
let's see a few more headlines
the original Metroid Prime game is
remastered on Nintendo switch give it to
me
I want it in my veins
I'm ready to go God Nintendo really does
just mock it on Nostalgia a lot and it
works
over and over and over again it works
and I keep I just
they maybe own me I maybe belong to
Nintendo
that's why I always find it funny when
anyone calls me a PlayStation or an Xbox
show because it's like are you aware of
the Nintendo shell I am dude come on now
[Music]
it does seem a little bit mean to give
us
Metroid
All Things Considered though
foreign
ER of a video game
[Applause]
[Music]
but not quite the Metroid everybody's
waiting for originally released on the
Nintendo GameCube system has been
mastered for Nintendo switch
I think it might be perspective
where there might be it's like it's in
my top 20 Guy video games I think visors
are the key to your adventure they'll
help you discover influent Clues on how
to progress
depending on the situation A Certain
visor may be required
when hostile creatures
attacks very good then fight back with
beams
missiles
also like for a remaster I feel like it
looks exceptional maybe I should go back
and look at the original Prime this
remaster adds new dual stick control
like this allowing you to move around
while separately changing your point of
view okay I should look at it side by
side I feel like this looks very good
creates the feel the original game among
other control options
explore Talon 4 with your preferred play
style
the digital version of Metroid Prime
remastered Launches on Nintendo eShop
when later today today physical version
of the game will be available it's out
now February 22nd oh my God
put your master detectives I'll be doing
that this weekend that's sick love to
hear it it's the world detective dude
this is a really good direct so far
a city ruthlessly controlled by
Amaterasu Corporation
alongside Master detectives
each one has a supernatural ability that
can prove useful during investigations
mimic body types and voices with
disguise
detect heartbeats and Whispers with
audio aptitude
and witness past crime scenes with
post-cognition that sounds like it would
suck I feel like that would make me sad
it's cognition so use them to get closer
to crack very cyberpunky after
collecting enough evidence a mystery
Labyrinth will appear
spot the inconsistencies and uncover the
truth
Master detective archives raincoat
Launches on Nintendo switch June 30th
[Music]
wings of the Heart Take Flight once more
a remastered collection of both button
kaido's games originally released on the
Nintendo system is coming to Nintendo
switch after a long and peaceful ERA
this is like a very retro heavy um
closer I'm all right again I am already
aware of that and I accept it
you'll stand up to the Empire across two
different eras of War
and team up with like-minded allies
you'll visit various locales it's such a
weird marketing phrase why don't you
take the bananas
get the potassium my man that power is
determined by the attributes in
combinations we'll visit various places
and meet people in this RPG real-time
battles you'll need to make split-second
decisions to Edge closer to this Baldo
looking [__] what Revelations
will come to light in the skies above
and the lands below
thought in kaidos one and two that text
is the font is terrible this summer you
should rethink that
dive into your new Fantasy Life various
daylight
[Music]
in a new Fantasy Life game
a girl who steals time while exploring
the once thriving Island
you'll meet a mysterious girl nice
that's all I've ever wanted go to it
then cool Island and meet a mysterious
girl it's like the top of my bucket list
to me that's actually all I want
[Music]
become a Woodcutter angler
cook blacksmith
Paladin magician and more it's very cute
take on different roles to develop the
island
how will you rebuild
this life is yours to live
[Music]
after 1 000 years the restoration is
about to begin
Fantasy Life off yeah oh Fantasy Life I
I just assumed it was like
one but there's already a fantasy life
which
um I also did not play
Leighton
I'd recognize that hat anyway oh my God
he's back
[Music]
the love of my life
oh my God I even watched the movie
[Laughter]
that's it what's he doing
I've got it
Yoshi's Island brand new course holy
[__]
my love for Professor Layton is uninjed
[Music]
Birdo who originally hit the track in
Mario Kart Double how do I feel about
rumors Nintendo will be raising prices
to 70 it's rumors I have no feelings
foreign
[Music]
Deluxe Booster course pass DLC for the
Mario Kart Mario caught eight maybe like
one of the best supported games of all
time this spring next to like fortnite
so many updates online plus expansion
pack members can enjoy this DLC at no
additional cost the DLC can also be
purchased on its own
[Music]
game does look really good Zelda thank
you
Zelda Zelda Zelda this will be our last
segment please take a look
I swear to God
all right Zelda okay look good
to use the Fallen Kingdom
okay okay okay
everybody shut up
rise rise my servants
sweep over Hyrule eliminate this king is
it the same man
there's no survivors
it is the same map that's interesting I
don't know if Zelda's ever done that
before
[Music]
oh that looks different
that's cool
[Applause]
sure you'll be able to stop him
so there's that there is obviously a
bunch of like content literally in the
sky
cool
what
[Music]
you can like craft vehicles
oh my God
[Music]
nuts and bolts you're absolutely right
lend him your power holy [__]
also was that Matt moster in this
trailer
oh my God I was so worried it would get
delayed dude
that was The Legend of Zelda tears of
the Kingdom the latest I'm gonna have to
just rewatch a whole bunch of times it
was
it was Matt that's awesome that's so
cool I'll have to reach out to him
containing various items we'll release
on launch day I love various items
figure of link from this game will also
be available on the same day
we hope you're looking forward to Link's
latest Grand Nintendo is like crash
because of all the pre-orders that's all
from today's Nintendo Direct wow thank
you for watching
oh my God
there's a lot in this that I loved okay
I need to re-watch that trailer after
the stream to pay more attention to it
all right
definitely excited about various
um
items this is really good
um some games I don't care about that's
always the case in a Nintendo Direct
though but what I love about them is
that for the games that I'm not
interested in like whatever that fashion
game was and there were some retro games
that I hadn't played which is like it's
cool to see
one they always have very good music
consistently two the pacing is so good
like they always just jump through
everything so far so that I just never
feel like I'm getting bored
I think that like Nintendo directs
they're just nailing it like
there's not a lot of talking they don't
even really need the interstitials I
feel like they just kind of do that to
break things up
um
yeah they really do get to the point
Through The Tick Tock crowd
uh huge shout out to my boy Leighton
huge shout out to my boy Professor
Layton huge fan to the extent that I
considered getting a latent tattoo at
one point and the context of that is
that my mom and I played those games
together
um and watched the movie together and so
it's like it became like a family thing
where you just like [__] love late
and also I think he's like hilarious
like I think Professor Layton does not
get the credit he deserves he's a
brilliant comedian do I think this will
be the last huge Nintendo game for the
switch
that's a great question no
because we're still waiting on Metroid
so I wouldn't I wouldn't say that I
would consider myself a generally
positive person I'm definitely a
generally positive person as is the case
for all my reactions to video games I
love them no point being mad I'm sure
there are a bunch of people who are mad
about this direct I haven't seen any
reaction to it whatsoever but I thought
this one was really really really good
um again the pacing the variety in it
solid and the amount of things that I
really really liked
um
yeah this is a this is a really really
good direct I didn't expect that to be
like oh cropped I was trying to explain
to somebody recently who's not really a
gamer
who just started playing I think it was
my hairdresser actually who just started
playing breath of the wild and I was
trying to explain why the physics is so
impressive in breath of the Wild
them taking the thing that was fantastic
about breath of the wild already which
again isn't something that like anyone
really expected in a Zelda game until we
started playing with and seeing the
crazy stuff people could do with it
um
I guess we're going to be like fantastic
physics and to just lean on that
and expand it in in tears of the Kingdom
which is what it looks like I keep
calling it taste of the Fallen King it
was just tears of the Kingdom
um it's such a good idea and I guess
people love the bike too right like
people really really love that
oh that's so cool